c'est parti on va jouer à la patate
chaude la patate chaude ses sabres une
minute trente de questions sur les
médias vous jouez également avec nous
chez vous bien entendu celui dés que
vous répondez mal un oeuf donc quand
vous retombe vous répondez mal vous
devez répondre à chaque fois vous passer
la patate chaude celui qui a la patate
chaude à la fin d une minute trente
il sert à se faire consulter par amir
d'accord je sais que je mathieu a très
envie de faire consulter par année mais
cela a gelé dans des sacs qu'il n'y a
pas la buissière s'y est pas la bouche
alors attention on va démarrer par vous
d'accord parce que vous êtes le nouvel
entrant lyonnais la patate chaude avait
très chaude à voilà attention c'est
parti unique strange question dans
quelle émission de ses huit des
célébrités rencontre des enfants dans
une salle de classe totalement bien sûr
elle est passée à qui vous voulez quel
est le nom de la dresseuse de titres de
fort boyard
je sais pas quelle punition a terminé à
venir lors de l'eurovision 2005 6e
trophée le véritable nom de stéphane
bern et stéphane bern
[Applaudissements]
attention delphine quel chanteur a
déclaré hier l'émission le meilleur
pâtissier c'est d'adapter à moi à junas
clair non pas du tout il sait jamais en
montagne il a déclaré que l'émission
s'est adapté à son handicap
quels instruments de musique a rendu
célèbre et des zus et lisse dessert ça
je vous le dit non annoncée d'un pot 3
et je vous dis il ya une nouvelle règle
c'est comme dendal si ça change à chaque
fois je vous le dis là trop d'autos si
vous répondez mal à trois questions
d'affilée c'est vous qui avez le gage
quel footballeur brésilien serait ruiné
il n'aurait plus que six euros sur son
compte en banque
alors ben et des médias non et oui à
l'âme à long terme et
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]